it's time for another challenge Charlie
over the years of doing challenge
Charlie many many many of you have
suggested that I spend a video trying to
talk in my bestest American accent and
last week when I asked for challenge
suggestions the majority of you asked
for me to speak to my best American
accent beauty of those chubby Poor's
Justin Bieber over 400 55m laying an egg
MJ toki 88 calimary 79 a little
mind-label Dominque just a few of the
people who suggested this challenge and
now I'm finally going to do it or should
I say have already done it because while
I usually spend my weekends making a
youtube video this weekend I was doing
staggered decade was a live 24-hour chat
to try and raise money for the charity
UNICEF so right in front of the crew of
people that were working on stick 8 and
in front of the about 10,000 people who
were watching the livestream I got my
camera and made my video so here I am on
the set of stick 8 trying for your
enjoyment to speak in my best American
accent here it is hello I'm at sticking
at the moment as you can tell from a
t-shirt and the echo and I'm looking at
a live chat the moment and people who
are hopefully going to suggest things
for me to say quintessentially American
things for me to say in my best American
accent I need some coffee I need some
coffee
how's that
I need a glance of books it I need a
glass of water water I need a
cheeseburger I need a cheeseburger
I've never made a video that's tied like
a laughs Detroit this is really fun for
me my gloves oh my god
squirrel squirrel squirrel dude these
waves too gnarly dude these waves are
gnarly hey mom hey mom how are you doing
how you doing
Garrett garage oh come on baby
oh come on baby do you like mussels do
you like waffles aluminium aluminium
pink girl hey hey girl hey oh man oh man
pink tone today Oh
holla at ya boy come we're doing this
one holler ne-yo holler at your boy
holler I know that's not a schedule
schedule so I'm going to Disney World
I got a Disney World hey I'm walking
here hey I'm walking here walking what
what hey I'm walking here
there's a snake in my boots there's a
snake in my boots oh no you don't go
friend oh no you don't girlfriend dude
that did not just happen dude that did
not just happen
tomato tomato how much wood would a
woodchuck chuck if a woodchuck to the
trip a wooden how much wood would a
woodchuck would chuck wood oh no you
didn't somehow you didn't previously on
Ugly Betty previously on Ugly Betty life
is like a box of chocolates laughs is
like a box of chocolates you'll come
back now you hear y'all come back now
you hear it's time to the woody
get out way get out of way let's go to
Mavs no that's all we have time for here
on Charlie is so cool like I'll see you
next time when I'm speaking normally
decayed itself was exhausting but
absolutely awesome I tell you it was
10,000 pounds but by the end of it
people had donated just under 20,000
pounds so almost double what we had
hopeful thank you so much to everybody
that came even if it was just for a
little bit
and also thank you so much to everybody
who donated to UNICEF I'm gonna go now
but uh see you next week you're
something all right
bye you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching charlieissocoollike
which makes you like cool